this is how maluwalden earns his living
in South Sudan's capital Juba he should
have been in his final year in high
school but dropped out before finishing
sixth grade
I left school because of the costs there
is no one to give me money to pay school
fees and other necessities because there
is no money at home the money I get from
washing cars is just enough to help feed
the family but not to put me back in
school
access to education and rate of
in-school children are some of the
indicators of development and South
Sudan has been performing badly years of
conflict and displacement has landed
South Sudan among the least developed
countries in the world more than half of
the 12 million people have limited
access to health care and education
maternal and infant mortality here are
among the highest in the world and the
economy has been on a downward spiral
since the war in 2013 making life hard
for many here
things are becoming more and more
expensive every day employment is hard
and when you try to set up your own
business it fails because the market is
almost at a standstill
despite being on the list South Sudan's
government has been absent from the U.N
conference on the least developed
countries being held in qatar's capital
Doha South Sudanese Civil Society
activists who are present say the low
pace of development is affecting women
the most women in the Grassroots in
South Sudan they don't have skills they
don't have informations
to to
business management that's why we
thought that it is very important to
empower them to give them the skills to
train them so that they will be able to
be part and fossil of the building of
the nation
despite its absence from the conference
South Sudan will be able to receive
International assistance but those in
the country say its presence would have
helped shed light on the areas where
such assistance is most needed Heber
Morgan Al Jazeera